it's so populated it's also like so it's
so la it's so Beverly Hills I lived
there for 13 years Jared yeah there was
a wave there that Laird was having a
love affair with for many years so we
lived there with you know so he could be
close to his girlfriend this sounds
strange it no every boy needs their
girlfriend every boy needs a wave they
do well girl you know just something
that's what at least I think is kind of
natural is at least from my experience
is like I don't know if you ever go
through this when you go home I'll layer
it'll go out and surf for many hours
like he can go on for five hours at a
time and if their surf and it comes home
and I see how happy he is like to see us
like he loves us he's like oh my girls
you know and then about I don't know
seven and a half eight minutes in he
starts to get this look on his face like
oh yeah I'm in the house like family you
know I wanted to do a book years ago
called death by domestication because
it's like how does how do how does he
manage both of those sides like I need
to go I need to be free I need to you
know chase things and like scare myself
and do all this stuff and then you know
comes home and it's like you know on the
floor laying you know with one of my
daughters and and being attentive and a
great husband and all these things but I
always get amused a little bit by the
push/pull yeah well especially I think
with the big wave surfer mindset my good
type of person those are like some of
the freest wildest humans on the planet
it's a very unusual group of people that
rides giant waves of water on the top of
the ocean I mean that's a that's a crazy
thing to dedicate your time to think
about it I tried not to think too much
about it because I did marry him but
there's some stuff I mean and weirdly
you know he's been doing this so long
that you realize hit he's actually even
more different than some of the other
guys because if you think about it he's
sustained doing this for right now forty
years so he's a guy who he has both so
what he wants to do is write a huge wave
during the day and
and be with his family at night and
sometimes you know it would take going
you know halfway around the globe or
whatever and so I think the pursuit and
they have to wait a lot that's the other
thing these things don't come around
that often right it's it's very
interesting to live with because there's
a there's a little bit of suffering that
goes on and sometimes Laird will say to
me because he's aware of time going by
he'll be like you know I have a lot more
waves I need to ride and I'm like I know
like it's a pretty deep calling and now
that I mean he's been foiling for 25
years but now that they are getting that
equipment better it's sort of like now
we can ride places that we couldn't ride
that we're not really attractive for
riding on top of the surface of the
water even if you towed it so now it's
opened up a whole other pursuit for him
yeah it's very light as to why you would
go towards that like layer just put me
on a ski in front of a wave that's like
60 feet right and like being on the back
of a ski with him driving there's a
moment where you go okay I actually and
I'm sure you've experienced this with
other friends that take you maybe I'm
flying or something he is this is what
he does right so I'm like okay I trust
him more than I'm afraid that's fine I
can do that and I'm gonna surrender to
that I'm not going to torture myself the
whole time I'm just gonna trust him and
you turn and there's a six story
building behind you moving and you just
think who would who like how is that fun
yo like how is seeing like I'm gonna
ride that but now what the foils because
they're actually catching the energy
below the surface of the water
what's up Voyles I'm not they have these
things called Hydra foils so originally
there's a guy named Mike Murphy who
created something called the air chair
and they were they've been putting foils
on like water skis and different funky
ways like even in the 50s so Laird and
his friends got an air tear and cut the
chair off and put us snowboard boots
bindings quick-release so you stand on
it you're booted in and
whoa is this basically a mini airplane
with a strut so for example yeah there's
a shot of one and this is a smaller one
Jamie do you have any ones of the big
with the boots I think this is what
people are used varies do you know what
about this wow he knows about everything
what are you talking about he's plugged
in is plugged in look at him give her
girlfriend
well what happened to this dude's head
oh yeah
so there's Laird on the left obviously
so you see how he they're in the boots
and also he the reason he looks so puffy
is he has floatation underneath his
wetsuit so if you hit your head or what
have you but it's basically a miniature
airplane underneath the surface and if
he gets into trouble if they wiped out
they have a quick release but now
they've gotten this developed so that he
can do it without the boots because that
adds an element of danger that because
you're strapped in you're strapped in
and you're strut is you know four feet
long you know that's so strange looking
yeah but what's going on below the
surface so there's a miniature airplane
do you have Jamie do have any pictures
of it flipped up I'm sure if you look on
Laird stuff you can see the bottom it's
like a miniature airplane because water
is denser than air so it's sort of like
a miniature plane and it is like the
Oracle guys that do those boats do have
made foils for Laird it's yeah so those
are kind of more low performance ones
when you see the high performance they I
mean you know aerodynamics hydrodynamics
it's all of that so now what you're
doing is because there's energy below
the surface moving so we think of a wave
like pushing and dropping but there's
actually the energy circular energy
below so now you've got the foil that
can ride that but you're not you don't
have drag so like they can go there's a
wave on kawaiii where they're going over
you know 50 big Oh about 50 they can go
up get up to 52 miles an hour so imagine
if you did something well you've you
know dedicated yourself to martial arts
it's like but then there's like a new
way to do it
and so he's been doing the big stuff for
25 years but now they're getting the
equipment right that he can ride ways
that actually wouldn't be that great but
now they're super fun Wow
so he gets it makes him excited and he
still pursues it and that's how that's
on Kauai right there and see how it's
not even breaking where he rides it yeah
so it no drug correct and it's it's
actually riding the energy below the
surface which you know for him he's just
interested in what's the most efficient
way I mean look at that you'd never
entered in regular surfing be able to
ride that so it enables them so much fun
you're flying that's what they sing
credible that's what it's the difference
right so they're flying so that's I
think keep kept him interested but you
know his his pursuit of this is it's
pretty it's pretty it's a pretty
interesting relationship to watch I
think it's important I mean as a female
for me I think playing volleyball help
me understand like having a pursuit you
know like something like you I got to go
do that and I think it's something about
living with a person who has a pursuit
other than like I need a bigger war
chest or whatever right that's can be
really cool